[Music]
oh was crazy oh hey welcome back
everybody to another special episode of
the careful boys where we are so blessed
today to have three of the buffest dudes
on
YouTube here you know what I mean
getting a little too hot so we got Jared
over here harder to do your dance moves
Now by being
so it's it's an issue and you know I'm
glad that I'm here on the show with such
professionals like yourself Dr Mike to
talk about it because I know there's a
huge dance demographic out there that
you know once they come become buffed
they can't move as well and I just want
to speak with professionals about it so
where do I get
steroids I tell you exactly
where
um the Yakuza run the whole trade so
your uncle I
guess look at all these tats this
[__] this is by the way folks
listening and watching
if you see a [__] dress like
this exactly like this never ever [__]
with him ever cuz his uncles have uncles
his uncles have uncles uncles do for
they're great uncles they don't do a lot
of for living it's a front dude it's all
Hong Kong action Cinema so it's all just
fake for camera you look like a Triad
for sure good enough yeah I do want to
know where to get steroids though that's
when I was in Mexico you know what BW my
mind is there'll be like a pharmacy and
it'll just be a list of all the things
that they sell there and I'm like I
could have sworn half of this thing was
illegal in America I've seen it too but
how do you know which one to get and
what to trust though Mexico Thailand
Thailand you got to know your science
you got to know your compound and then
what it does but it is crazy cuz it's
like Tylenol and then a poster of Ronnie
Coleman and then the biggest array of
steroids you've ever seen in your life
in Mexico right yeah and you could just
buy it you could just buy ibuprofen or
[__] benad dril and then [__]
testosterone all together okay so
hypothetically my friend would get k out
there if if I wanted to begin my
steroidal Journey not me obviously but
hypo somebody like me like how how does
one even get the intelligence and
information to know which one to get
like what's the next
step you know what I'm saying you could
look for a coach somebody who talks
about this stuff openly we know a few
people who talk about it openly and
teach people about it actually there are
so we don't teach much about steroid so
we don't know that much but there are
people in in the industry um that their
job is to be experts in anabolics and um
all performance nancing drugs wow they
will teach you and and help you take
them so reach out to those guys and uh
is there a way to like okay so you know
like they say oh steroids you know it's
going to you're going to get buffed but
your dick's going to disappear some they
have crazy things that happen right is
there an opposite where you're like hey
you might lose a lot of muscle but
you're going to have really good sex
organs huge dick yeah is there like a
opposite if you guys find out please let
us know it's called surgery oh okay what
do they put into your dick to make uh
they'll just like pull that extra like 2
Ines out or whatever they do have those
they they can they can increase the
girth or or the length and or the length
or that's some [__] damn or you try
for both can't have the best of both
worlds dud it's either thick or long but
they do also have like uh for people who
have like severe Ed the pole thing they
put in your dick they do do that the
needle she's like are you hard [__]
I've been hard since
2008 the
procedure what's the poll thing I have
no idea they pump it like as an old
person you can like stick in a needle
pump it every single time so it's not
like a one time thing your hard always I
got a question basketball have you guys
seen RFK
workout uh Robert F Kennedy no uh so
he's a buff old guy just presidential
candidate if you could pull up a video
of them he was working out at Venice
Beach and I was like oh he's kind of
ripped for like a 70-year-old so I was
wondering if you could tell if he is on
steroids or if that's natural says
Robert F Kennedy working out a lot of
guys who are still training very very
seriously in their 70s 80s are usually
on like trt or GH or a combination of
the two what's what's trt testosterone
replacement therapy go to a doctor and
man the Illuminati has been good to this
[__] holy [__]
I'm like an Illuminati Junior like
Illuminati kids basically and they don't
give us half the [__] they give
in they probably on something or no most
likely on tough to tell it's a very
distinct redness to his skin but then
also he's like 90 or some [__] well is
that just like why person in the Sun for
like 10
minutes yeah it's difficult to tell I
mean like uh CU that's achievable
natural too right for some people you're
young yeah gen got
before and maintained it like then that
would be if he has really good genetics
he could sort of get that anytime in his
life with a few years of training we'
had a few RP clients who lifetime drug
free and are still and they like one of
them was like a grandmother and then she
discovered she liked lifting and then
she just had like two years later she
had [__] ripped abs and big arms and
[__] yeah like a goog like CrossFit
Grandma did she live her whole life with
that undiscovered potential correct yeah
she was yeah she was like Wolverine but
like a farmer and then like and she
didn't even know she could have been
jacked until she just lifted her first
weights and then unlock something a huge
Discovery W that's like movie [__] yeah
what is what is that though good
genetics like that just sounds like you
know some people got it some people
don't it's like unfair is that just life
is unfair for some of us people are just
strong that's literally what that means
how do you tell if you have bad genetics
I
know more rethorical I know someone
that's always tearing ligaments all the
time and I'm like that's bad that's
probably bad genetics yeah it's like you
don't got good joints dude he's trying
to tackle tractors you're like oh that
is probably the problem your could be
quite good Jamal Duncan in fifth grade
that's good genetics Jamal Duncan
dude it was Julius for me the
EAS the easiest way to tell if you have
good genetics for lifting is if you just
do some [__] like just start working out
who gives a [__] what it's called
download a DVD a digital video disc and
and work out with
that CH like how old is this [__] uh
get a cassette tape play some play play
some tape C
tape yes laser disc is good pop in a
Russ Russell Simmons or Richard Simmons
one of those little Tinker but like
music box you're trained that [__] was
godamn it but anyway if you just do some
[__] like that forget the music box
right you got Beethoven playing live to
the orchestra comes people know me for a
few things one is that I'm like there's
rich
people and then I'm like right
here actually scroll through the page
yeah I have visualiz the Philadelphia
philarmonic will play betoven
masterpieces live in my
gym and listen I got you one rule one
rule two rules that's really what you
train to in my [__] gym was Asian
household so we don't have you really
train to that yes and also first string
only me I know all you faces too [__] I
and you know what to be honest like the
cello no offense only Chinese people get
to touch my [__] cello yoyo Ma so
only yoyo ma comes over I'm sorry just
better at it yeah and when I'm getting
that nice rep I need to hear that
Chinese [__]
how good so
only Y no one else I
digress any type of [__] you start
working out a couple months later if
you're seeing some visible results you
probably have pretty [__] decent
genetics I didn't mean to look at you in
your fine ass
body we are and I tell myself I'm
straight all the time and the viewers
also assuming I'm
straight want a lot of muscle since the
last time I no seriously he's been he's
been working hard this guy you know
what's funny like as much as it's like
funny in the beginning I keep random
looking at the thumbnail and I I'm
starting to get a little insecure you
shouldn't you shouldn't you shouldn't
put your yakuzi jacket back H thank you
thank you thank
you needed a [__]
out it is a Yakuza jacket if it's been
like only a few months of training and
you're going pretty hard at it and
you're eating okay and you're really
struggling to see anything happen or
struggling to see any kind of strength
increase there is a probability that
you're messing up some kind of deeply
systemic variable in your approach and
somebody could just just click it in
place and you'll have magical gains
there is that probability but it's low
and if you're struggling early it's like
you know it's like if if you're like no
offense again if you're like Jewish
parents of a Jewish child and you're
like we want them to play in the oh the
National Football League with the
monsters you know day one in the [__]
Kitty leagues he gets his helmet knocked
off his body and passes out from asthma
non-
cont just running on the field Mor is
probably not go off and it's not like oh
but he had like a tough start but then
in eighth grade he really turned into a
[__] gorilla maybe yeah
but just go do math or whatever early
early on you can kind of like almost
like get a lot of information on what
the trajectory could could be yeah it it
maybe like a little less trajectory and
more how involved of a time are you
going to have to put into this to get
the kind of results that you want to see
and some [__] like like oh I
need to get in shape for my wedding
pretty much like later they have a
sixpack and [__] you that's so not fair
it's [__] and then some people are
like it's my life dream to step on a
bodybuilding stage and then years later
their friends are like don't do it man
don't do it people are going to laugh at
you you're not ready you're never going
to be ready even though you've been
cranking away that [__] it's unlikely
because it's a normal distribution and
most people have decent genetics you
know and some people have
like yeah and then some people are like
oh holy [__] you could just you're like
a [__] duck in water with this [__]
like Jamal Duncan Jamal's got it all
Jamal Jamal got it all yeah he does it's
probably a movie Somewhere I remember
him I remember I think like fifth grade
we had to run our first Mile and it was
like the playground had one of those
where you had to run four laps and I
just and I just remember he was like
literally like a lap ahead of everyone
and I'm just I didn't even understand
how he work that fast yeah were you mad
at him afterwards did you resent him a
little bit I got sad went behind the
bleachers and smoked a cigarette no I
had I had I had join a gang I had I had
good genetics when it came to math if
they had made you run to 13 Mile you
would have passed that [__] up
though it's all about perspective dude
people of West African descent which is
most black Americans um are
proportionally slightly uh on average
more likely to be faster twitch fiber
dominant than slower twitch fiber which
they're genetically slightly more likely
to be good explosive short distance
stuff and less likely to be good at
endurance stuff that's actually East
Africans and canyons and [__] like that
they're the best in the world with that
and they look very different like you
would never mistake them uh for for same
same and we had a kid in my high school
who was like a new transfer and he was
like you know like you know there's like
black guys and there's like Ah that's a
[__] just [__] just for no reason
[__] 16 years old he's like I'm
how are you an adult human he's like get
the [__] out of my way [__] ass kid he
touched me this is great day of my life
and so we were we did like two miles
running we our gym teacher was insanely
lazy and so he was like just go and we
ran in the neighborhood too he was just
like just come back and we had a route
and like I was always the kid that was
there were the cross country track kids
who did that [__] too they were always
in the front by themselves smoking I was
the first of the
regulars I was like I'm not going to
beat these track kids but [__] everyone
else and
then Jamal just runs right the [__] past
me in a half Sprint and I was like
they're better period yeah that's how it
goes it's like people bring up my
Nigerian friend you're like I don't give
okay he's a dentist and he's smarter
than me and he's beautiful he's also
jacked I don't care I just better it's
just better fine I what am I going to do
no right it's fast twitch though so
about 400 ft later he was just sitting
on the side of like just sitting on the
grass of a house
like and I was like what [__] it was
just that's it he just one more lap and
you had Jamal but later that week we
played [__] Flag Football oh my God I
thought he stepped on somebody's head
catching famous one day kid that guyy a
future NFL All Pro [__] out of here I
had the same story but in basketball I
did a 23 and me and then it said I'm all
slow twitch baby my man yeah me too you
don't you don't got nowhere to rush to
man yeah just take it easy but I that's
probably why I like endurance things
I just is there a way to like uh train
different would would you program
differently for someone that had fast
twitch versus like slow twitch subtly
yeah I never got into fast twitch type
of sports maybe because I just didn't
people realize there like you were all
slow twitch said on your ancestry report
so you were like I'm good at distance
stuff you you stuck with that shits
that's pretty fast twitch what's that
gang bws they last a while with him they
can last a while yeah it's like I like
the slow twitch Endurance on you bring
the knives they don't last too long
honestly I
like
surfing usually you go the direction of
what that's true competitive hiking yeah
I guess it depends on the mountain time
trials people have figured out some sh
some way to make hi they [__] ride
fake ponies man that is a funny ass
thing though oh when those girls are
jumping yeah what the [__] is that dud
could be a SP hate on it something's
happening there
to be able to jump over those things is
there a metric by which they are judged
compared to each other style I think
so one like right now there's like eight
people sitting around a table talking
the same [__] about bodybuilding so
probably probably we don't know I I had
body the same way this one girl really
judging like come on this one girl I
really liked in high school her and I
hung out for like a day in college and
she came over and I just for some reason
showed her a bunch of bodybuilding
magazines and I didn't expect this
reaction out of any human but she was
just like rifling through the pages and
she was like looking at their dicks and
she was like that guy's got a big dick
that interesting okay that guy's small
and I was like not once I've had these
magazines for years not once that I ever
look at anyone's dick I've seen a lot of
dicks in my life and some of
them take your breath away boys will be
boys you know what I'm saying just a
little locker room fun no big deal but
she's looking at the buls she's even
looking at just remember Jamal's got it
all Jamal's got it all names just
ethnicity say l yeah but she was super
like it's what she saw first and I was
like damn you can't fake being [__]
into man or whatever yeah F yeah it's
like have you seen that's the takeaway
have you seen the whole V the the videos
during fall where like o girls are like
guys are about to be sweat weather like
they like the they like yeah like the
gray sweatpants that's like their
cleavage cuz you can see the dick print
so they like it that's why I only wear
black sweatpants I don't even touch the
gray stuff yo dick pant dick prints are
[__] dude cuz like [__] dude cuz if
you're a like a what's that called a
grower it's not not a
shower yeah I never had be either very
true but like especially when it's cold
you grow you your shit's all up there
yeah and you know [__] judge you for
your [__] external estimate of dick
size and I just want to be like [__]
don't judge me just no hold up first of
all yeah you Jud away but Judgment Day
is coming back at you cuz your boy about
to be hard in a
second and then she's like okay all
right go be hard I'm like nervous judge
I'm on the spot crying and you're like
oh this is only 80% though CU you got to
make excuses you have to make right the
pressure catalog of excuses fellas I got
them all day I got a stack I don't sleep
enough the other day I was kind of tired
start rolling outu getting into it and
the [__] is like is this it I'm like
what's the barometric pressure today
shit's off right high pressure where're
the low pressure zone I'm on cycle I'm
off cycle doesn't matter onle some
anabolics make your dick not work off
cycle how the [__] my dick supposed to
work with no
anabolics so yin and yang and both of
them make your [__] dick not work as
hard does it ever feel like that where
you're like really horny but then you
can't get it up because of whatever it's
called so there's there's a a compound
called decad durabolin and uh nandrolone
decanoate and
some people a small minority though
nonetheless an extent fraction get to me
too get what's called Deca dick and it
makes you so DEA usually through a
variety of mechanisms makes you
profoundly horny like there's horny and
then there's like there's some blade
hunger for the serum type of
[__] I need it
please the the the Jerry scale of
Darkness goes goes like a little more
pale during those times I'm like okay
she's close enough you know yeah close
kind of looks if I go like
this uh but then but then you're Mr Mr
winky down there he don't want to play
so what do you do is it frustrating
mostly you you become aggressive at the
other person you blame them you're like
[__] it's cuz you cuz you can't do this
you have mental
breakdown it turns [__] on like you
wouldn't believe they want to fix you
they go my God he's got psychiatric
problems I love
him then you're in but you're in I can
fix him right see there you
go I can fix this in your house look
like that but you know nonetheless it's
okay what's the pros to it like what
what what does it do to your body where
where it's worth that well you get in a
relationship afterwards no the
part that's all for the relationship
what is it strength makes you really big
and strong look at the cap
boy ISO dead you have beautiful skin oh
thank you don't worry all Asians have
beautiful skin just a placeholder
compliment God damn it he's got de di
he's being angry right now okay and I
can fix him I can fix him can you fix
him right here right now turn off the
camera um no your skin is excellent
thank it really is so uh a lot of times
drug use is like typified by a few
things some people can get away with it
but like I'm saying like the [__] is
that yeah like is there parts of you
that are sandpaper yeah jar your Skin's
exists I'm white um but anyway yeah it
just makes you like like put on Jack
strong yeah dang it's a steroid and you
know about 20 minutes here so to end the
episode if you want some steroid just
[Laughter]
[Applause]
afterwards
for